the new york times ran this story the
smaller bombs that could turn ukraine
into a nuclear war zone a photo released
by russian state-owned news agency
showing the iskinder m launch vehicle
being loaded with a ballistic missile
during military exercises at a russian
firing range in the how do you pronounce
that you sure
you suryask
in 2016.
now this is this is great in destructive
power the behemoths of the cold war
dwarfed the american atomic bomb that
destroyed hiroshima washington's biggest
test blast was one thousand times as
large moscow's was three thousand times
on both sides the idea was to turn
strikes with threats of vast retaliation
with mutual assured destruction or mad
the psychological bar was so high that
nuclear strikes came to be seen as
unthinkable today both the russia russia
and the us have nuclear arms that are
much less destructive their power just
fractions of the hiroshima's bomb's
force their use perhaps less frightening
and more thinkable so this is what i was
talking about a few weeks ago when i
said nuclear war can it seems to me to
be uh possible
and um but tim it's okay it's good for
the environment remember the media came
out and said that it's good for the
environment well that was ten years ago
i think usa today had run an op-ed
saying a small nuclear war could be good
for the environment
so what i'm what i'm saying is we might
see nuclear artillery we're going to see
russia will use in my opinion if they
need to if they are losing i would mean
i would not be surprised if russia does
use nukes i don't know let me make sure
i'm clarifying this i don't know if the
probability that russia uses uses this
is 10 or 2 percent 50 or 1 percent but
vladimir putin continually threatens to
use nukes as he will not back down there
are a lot of people who fear that nato
doesn't care they're reckless or biden
is completely inept and what we'll end
up seeing is russia they keep reporting
is being backed into a corner i don't
completely believe that i think it would
be absurd to think ukraine could beat
russia russia's a massive power even if
it's not as big as nato it's like half
as big as nato
but if russia gets pressed uh if russia
gets pressed by nato they may say okay
let's land the big guns gravity bombs
may be something not as big as hiroshima
or nagasaki but powerful bombs they're
already using the thermobaric bombs
these things are crazy the missile comes
out comes down ejects fuel spraying it
all through the air and then sucks all
the air and explodes like just
vaporizing people so they've already got
very very powerful but lower yield
weapons if putin had to i think he would
use it if nato intervenes i think it's
possible he does and then i'm worried
about what happens to europe will we
will we actually see russia say you're
not going to nuke us back we can do what
we want and then you know honestly i was
thinking about it earlier because
there's a conspiracy theory
someone predicted a year ago what's
happening now and so this this meme's
going viral or some guy's like here's
going to happen with russia and the next
step they said was that nato would get
involved russia would threaten nuclear
weapons nato would call their bluff
russia would say ho yeah and then fire a
nuke and then you get nuclear war i'm
not entirely like i it seems far-fetched
but i also think it would be silly for
us at this point it would be uh it would
be optimism and normalcy bias to think a
nuclear war would never happen i think
specifically you're talking about
explosive nuclear weapons too because uh
the americans in iraq and the second
iraq war use depleted uranium weapons
because in order to penetrate armor in a
tank that's made with the depleted
uranium you need depleted uranium
bullets so they just sprayed them across
the desert they're underground in the
desert irradiating the land yeah we're
talking about that's a nuclear war so
not all nuclear weapons have have a
radio radioactive yield
uh that's intentional so some of them
actually don't some of them are just
concussive shock waves or explosive but
yeah i mean you know what are your
thoughts do you think where do you think
this goes and and what would you do see
all i would say to that is what what's
to deter russia from using nuclear
weapons to keep that they want to keep
their country intact and they want to
keep ukraine intact but do you really
think that russia fears the u.s does
russia fear nato does russia fear anyone
right now i mean we right now we were
you know under donald trump and even
trump came out and said this russia
didn't act this way putin didn't act
this way when trump was in office
because trump was a respected leader
whether or not the left wants to say
that or not like he was you know off the
cuff no one ever knew what was going to
happen with him look what happened with
uh soleimani and iran when they messed
with america donald trump you know
brought down the hammer look at russia
right now they're not fearful of
anything they're not fearful of
retaliation because we're not a
superpower anymore i really you know
would venture to say that and again with
the whole nato situation i'm not a
geopolitical expert so you know inform
me on this point but like what is really
to stop russia from doing this well we
the u.s is a superpower the issue
any more perspective
is that thucydides trap looms
and uh there's a there's a one of one of
these there's a conspiracy theory that
western powers for the past 20 years
have known through cities trap is a real
possibility and as we've already shown
all of you the liberal world order
exists the council on foreign relations
explains this and they say there will be
a new world order one of the theories is
that
the powerful elites of the council on
foreign relations the trilateral
trilateral commission etc i mean these
are organizations that outright just say
they're doing these things and you can
call it a conspiracy i don't know
whatever maybe they're lying but cfr is
newsguard certified they say there's a
liberal world order
now these people have to be aware of
thucydides trap that us growing us is is
is a large economic power the largest
and china is growing as an economic
power and that means world war iii is
likely if your intention is to prevent
world war 3 then you need to stop
thucydides trap from happening well you
can't stop china from growing so what do
you do you cut off the tall grass in the
u.s you [ __ ] the united states so
that they fall as fast as china rises
and thus you avoid a war i'm not saying
that's true but i'm saying it's
certainly you know one theory about the
policies enacted by the binding
administration and the obama
administration that have seemingly hurt
the united states and not even them i
mean george w bush and bill clinton as
well yeah well i don't even believe the
narrative that the nuclear war is going
to happen i i think it's always possible
right there's always everything's
possible ian might give me a million
dollars so possibly it is possible we
never actually know uh but ultimately
speaking i think this is to stoke the
fear with this idea if there was going
to be a real nuclear attack i don't
think the media would actually be
discussing this i think we'd be in
preparation mode and something would be
announced with like a genuine
understanding hey
this is like like how they did with
russia how they go
they are going to invade on this day
like this is what's going to happen and
no one heard about this until russia was
going to invade now of course i joked
about it that week ago that was the zero
day war because they kept getting it
wrong and if you leave it to the
administration to literally
be stupid enough to like announce the
exact day that he knows he's going to
invade as if you know he's going to be
like okay i'll go ahead and keep for the
date so we don't change our dinner plans
um but you know he ended up invading he
ended up going in inside and and going
uh you know first the peacekeeping
mission and then moving forward but
ultimately everything i hear is about
creating hatred not just for russia but
for russians and the hatred for russians
is why i don't believe the nuclear side
because anything they can use to get
people to distance themselves and
recreate an iron curtain an iron wall
between that nation seems to be at hand
and there's one thing i know not
everyone cares about anything but
everybody knows nuclear war especially
boomers and people who grew up you know
and how to do the drills underneath
their desks they're aware of this
they've been around around the bush here
and they don't want that and nobody
wants that and that's why i think they
start to say like small nuclear warheads
because the chances of russia like they
know it's ludicrous letting off these
you know megaton warheads this is not
going to happen so they have to shrink
the threat this is the first time i've
ever heard in history and i might be
wrong where we're talking about you know
oh micro warheads and we're we're back
to micro penises and microwaves
everything's shrinking back we've been
talking about this for a few weeks no no
that's not what i meant i meant like not
this story today i i've heard this this
argument i meant now it's like where
they have to kind of change the threat
from something that we've never had this
global discussion on micro warheads to
like this might happen and i always feel
like with the ghost of kiev snake island
the video that came out today that you
mentioned on twitter it's been nothing
but propaganda
to the point that i just put pictures up
for my trip in ukraine and people needed
to debunk them like i'm sitting here
right now fast flight but the nuclear
war angle is actually preventing nato
from intervening
but i but i don't know but i don't i
don't think so though because i i think
that putin is pretty if you watch what
his speeches are not that i would
believe everything he says he's kind of
upfront about what he wants and i think
the issue even if you go back to noam
chomsky trying to explain what's been
happening inside of ukraine he's not
okay with it being militarized he does
not want it armed he wants a neutral
position between nato and russia he
knows these are two different worlds
could putin do anything anyone could
because we want a different idea for for
our society for our life it's a whole
new movement he cares about why why does
he want ukraine to be neutral because
it's right that's right at his border
he's not so is estonia and latvia yeah
but i think ukraine actually has i
believe they're more corrupted in terms
of with our own regime and government
it's a puppet arm of the united states
but estonia and latvia are nato members
yes but i'm saying i think ukraine
specifically like as we're seeing now i
don't know if we're gonna donate like
with georgia i don't think we're gonna
do i don't know if we're gonna really
donate arms and really fight as hard as
you would think but ukraine sits as a
middle puppet that we control that we
don't control but it's still for money
it's a us proxy it it is in my opinion
nothing to do with neutrality vladimir
putin wants access to their only warm
water port in crimea and if ukraine goes
eu they cut russia off
so russia moves in through the east they
go they go into the country they're
effectively trying to bifurcate from the
north and the south
ultimately i don't know where where
putin goes to this neutrality is i
believe part of his goal i think it's a
lot to do with him wanting to maximize
um
energy sales into europe which is what
you know essentially helps fund the the
russian economy but i think
crimea there's a reason he took it
instantly russia has one warm water port
in the black sea one warm water port
it's in the black sea it's crimea and
they need more than just you know going
south through crimea they need the the
land bridge to the north that i think is
why putin is doing it
he doesn't care about estonia and latvia
sure because he doesn't have anything
there he has kaliningrad he has access
to the baltic sea already so he doesn't
care about these other states
i mean it's an onion i think it's
multifaceted and i think if you've seen
this all we've heard about ukraine in
the last few years has been american
corruption money laundering elitist
families and even trump you saw that i
mean back that old clip where he's
literally sitting with zelensky saying
this is a very corrupt country that
deals with massive layers of corruption
meaning we've known this is a problem
state and putin's been aware of this too
but i'm just saying when me when noam
chomsky and me are agreeing that
something's very wrong in the world in
general saying in warning just in 2018
hey
the media has been deceiving the
ukrainian people western media into
thinking they can be a western nation
but it has been understood with
gorbachev on that any sort of push to
move western in ukraine would end in a
bloody war and would end in some sort of
you know uh aggression from the russian
government no matter what leader was in
power he was saying they're not going to
accept that and they're going to invade
so i'm just saying that you know they've
been duped just like we're standing with
ukraine i think the ukrainians don't
realize that the proxy that they have
and the importance of that position i
believe the west pushed this invasion to
be necessary i don't think if we hadn't
if we had pulled out not installed our
own regime not created a revolution
through social media i don't think this
would have happened now but i do believe
that because of the inability for the
west and the east to somehow leave some
country alone we can't leave anybody
alone this was going to happen you want
to know there's a simple reason why
ukrainians favor the eu and you know
what it is what holiday more
yeah that's that's that's really the big
so
it's a really horrifying story when i
yeah so uh russia wants to expand its
power they want the russian trade
federation the eu obviously wants to
expand wants the bread basket of europe
when i went to ukraine and talked to a
lot of people they all said we have the
opportunity to either join with russia
and have this trade federation which
would benefit us greatly or the eu which
would be you know very similar and then
a lot of people were like we don't trust
russia because they genocided our people
yeah the holdemore a man-made famine a
man-made famine convulsed the soviet
republic of ukraine from 1932 to 33. how
many people died how many people starved
to death like tens of millions so many
yeah because because uh the soviets
had disdain for the ukrainians as a
people
and
wanted to one man
but then in world war ii technically
still they gave a lot of their own lives
3.9 million kiev i mean or to like sort
of to fight in ukraine soviets i mean it
wasn't there's quite a bit of troops
soviets executed all the intellectuals
in in eastern europe took over the
communists were just like a a malignancy
of evil but russian history goes way
before the so the soviets i'm just
saying like that's obviously a period
but i'm not defending the soviet time
but i'm saying this idea of a russian
federation
of the russian people i i do believe
there is some shared understanding and
value i mean it's not too long ago with
with i'm not i'm not talking about my
opinion on russia i'm saying yeah the
ukrainians i spoke with said we don't
trust the russians we know it happened
20 years ago i mean what year was the
holonumber was like the late 32-33 i
wouldn't trust between 31 and 34.
and then you had just the soviet union
uh going until uh you know only 20 or 30
years ago so these people are like nah
i'm not interested
you know they're like we'll take the
capitalists in europe for all their
faults
so yeah but i think the media
brainwashed them into thinking that
could happen like that's my whole point
is that i like our media you know tells
us things that are absolutely false that
there was you know we were safe in in
afghanistan that it was going to be a
smooth pull out and it wasn't a smooth
pull out it was literally like a you
know end of prom night sloppy it was a
surrender a literal military surrender
and they said it wasn't like vietnam but
it was i'm saying i do believe that our
media that the influence by nato in the
west has tricked them into thinking that
they could be a part of the west without
a war and i'm not blaming them do
whatever the hell you want with your own
country you know like the russians fine
but just so you know if you want this
you're going to have the situation on
your hand with 10 million refugees and
that's i'm not blaming the people for
getting duped i'm saying i believe that
this was if this continued the way it
did as we're seeing it was going to be
unavoidable because russia wasn't going
to put up with it even if it's for
whatever reason you said or things that
we don't know because i'm not an expert
despite the joke that i'm an eastern
european war expert because everyone is
now um if i put a russia and a ukraine
flag in my bio so now i know i'm i i'm
an expert solidarity yeah uh i i just
gotta say i think we'll find out the
real point of this
as time goes on and if he's going to
push forward
no crap i mean i'm not going to accept
that i wouldn't accept russia pushing
further into europe and i don't think
any european country should and i hope
we don't ever get there thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there